all pro Pro Bowler and the guy that
flat-out gets it done and he tells the
truth and he's an unapologetic about it
Josh how you doing my man well what
quite a bit I mean you're like that you
are like I wish you were here because I
want to look in your eyes sit down and
talk to you I forgot what we were and I
said man we need to talk because I I
thought that you know we got some things
misconstrued in the past I'm not once to
look at yesterday cuz my neck don't even
go back that far to look behind me so I
like to look ahead but I I want you to
know I appreciate you I love your
audacity that you display I love your
climbing your plate to the top I respect
all of that and I respect you step it
out outside the lines and doing the
things that you love to do I mean dance
what to start everything man you've done
it you've taken this position you've
done some wonderful things we didn't
know and I appreciate it man that's big
man big time I got like I think looking
at late when you know we want to catch
up at Snoop Dogg's event yeah yeah each
other and it was something that we
needed to catch up on got together and
sat down and had a conversation because
it yeah I think we did get things
misconstrued it was that whole time and
that era back when Carolina is to
boating and you know just big
miscommunication and and I always looked
up you big time player anyway man you
and your heyday and the best of the best
that's for sure well I appreciate it man
I appreciate doing your thing and you
know it is good whenever we get that
chance now opportunity to have that
conversation but yeah I mean I
appreciate everything done for this
league and continue to do this team is
the team that I've picked to win the NFC
East and you guys are flat-out balling
offensively defensively special teams is
this what you envisioned when you went
to Washington
I did a lot of people out there legal
causing a name right now but they really
got us on low into that totem pole like
we never gonna beat it out of me but I
know me personally when I came here and
you know I started that roster and I was
J office man and I looked at that board
and I started telling and then when we
played them in Carolina and I saw what
they had you know in the arsenal man it
just was a couple pieces missing man and
you know you know coming in and looking
at that and seeing what you can do with
that man I knew that you know the
process of it was was going to be it was
going to be pain taking and for sure
anything you try to make good is gonna
take some time
Blake when all you know settle and when
there's a smoke and it does clear you
can see right now we are truly putting
things together and it's coming together
in a phenomenal way Alex Smith agent
Peterson just broke another record
yesterday the offense is rolling and
that the defense can be consistent can
you guys overtake the Philadelphia
Eagles which got back on track yesterday
well you know I think you know you gotta
be big in the trenches you not wind
fences you might well forget about it
true and and right now where we are in
the trenches Philly got a handful no
offense to anybody else but they got a
handful what we are doing over here is
we were creating problems for people
Mitch matches um inside you know when
the hand goes down there that kind of
mismatch and if it's really on men
against boys and right now we got some
grown man they young but they plan like
some it I liked it one of my
counterparts Shannon Sharpe he takes a
fence to Alex Smith he calls him checked
down Alex he don't even call him Alex
Smith he calls him checked down attics
and I defend Alex because everywhere
Alex Smith has gone he's won no he
hadn't won at all
cuz he hadn't had the pieces of the
puzzle win it all but the guy gets the
job done
what dynamic has he brought to this team
not turning the ball over Oh breach like
that's easy
I mean God leave man you already know
you got a solid defense and they give
you that ball back and we not turn the
ball over I mean what's the turnover
margin here we all know it you don't
know or like me to win the game so we
not turn the ball over on offense and we
let our defense get back over there we
turn the ball over
I think I tend though pretty bit more
higher than other things so as long as
we doing that ball is whatever care who
care what matters who gets the praise
and the glory only we doing it we win it
yeah you guys got Atlanta man in the
land as a seesaw
I'm so emotion about Atlanta because
that was my first love but there see so
man I'm so tired of being on that seesaw
right now man I don't know come on man
they got some dogs over there man
it's so enticing I mean any time you get
to go again Julio is oh that's a grown
man oh yeah that's a grown man man
absolutely you get the sweetest
competition the best it gets no better
it really does just know better so it's
just when you look at those guys and the
weapons they got you know your chances
are going to be high handle some balls
or do something to make a big play or
turnover or stop them from making a big
play it's always gonna be the lights on
you every snap because every play is
potential of a big one or you know I'm
saying or arm be what one everything man
I know we're past the episode with uh
O'Dell he said something yesterday man
and I love him
I really do but they asked him about
being there
is he happy that he's there with the
Giants and he said I'm here and I'm like
oh Dale come home man you can't say that
they obeyed you like this man have you
lost your mind
man look I don't understand it
you know that ship is it's whatever
reasons I mean whatever but I really
care that be honest man what I would get
it back together man he deserves
whatever right play any game you know
with him as a player and ODB I you know
you can say so much and don't you know
ridicule the people around you put it in
a day I mean that's how I feel about it
but yeah us looking outside you know and
be like come on you can do better they
just paid you all that yeah you gotta be
lender you gotta be part of the solution
wait are we talking about that's a
leader in him right now at the age he is
I mean he's still developed it true oh
well said Josh Wilson doing all these
things I mean we had a conversation on
the other day was like yeah man we need
some crazy stuff like turn into the game
to work like that all that stuff that is
you know really younger that was a kid
stuff you know growing up he was trying
I can see that you know I'm saying like
so for me take that and looking at it's
like man we had a good day yesterday you
know I'm saying like it was a good match
like I enjoyed it like that I think for
him just now the off the field things
and what he says is gonna take that step
to it so it's a maturity I mean it like
I said it is what it is I mean I think
some people wear their feelings on their
shoulders and then they they say what
they feel and they express themselves
but then others you know they say how
they feel but then they hide it by
saying different words
knowing they mean something else let me
see how you how you take this you know
cuz I had a I had an altercation with
Andre Rison back in the day when using
pampas you know he's usually shorty
there yeah that was my boy dog little
different relationship than you had with
hotel but after it was over after all
the homies like man you did this you did
this you the man you the dog you do this
I felt so bad cuz I couldn't believe
that we let it get there
I felt so bad inside and it's something
that we will always have to deal with
but is it any party you said just like
yesterday man we did some stupid things
that don't appeal what we even do that
man
yeah I mean is I feel bad I think got
caught up in the moment of what was
going on you know enough to do that like
we're gonna come back at you we're gonna
be within the ring um you know the line
of the game we try to be but did you
take it out there then you gotta go out
there so it's not something I can see
and look back and be like what dang I
wish I did this differently I wish I did
it me personally I wish I would put my
helmet off but like I said when we get
older we start to look back and you
start to think about things and realize
that you know that was some crazy stuff
we did back then but do I say you know
at the moment at times I regret man that
back then like you said earlier you know
you turn it around you'd be like oh
shoot what oh man II can't can't go back
in it that's what happened so we gotta
move forward but when we do get outside
of game we look care this be like we can
hopefully sit down and laugh about it
one day no man you you are so mature you
you so to me you hear
you're gonna exceed football man what
are your life plans because it football
is not football is what you do that's
not who you are so I can see that in you
my brother I really can and just hearing
you articulate yourself what do you want
to do what it's done when it's over man
you know I been through the blast man
guys truly bless me is so many more talk
fast at ways that stone it really is
that's one like all the stuff
was coming down on top of our heads like
we lost against on New Orleans and
everybody tried it like to have a
firestorm me day or something like I
gave who else live to be really careful
I know what I have going on I know me
and the stuff that I got going on I was
so much bigger than this it's just like
it don't even bother me I move because
when you go self-made like nothing
affects you true like that didn't even
affect me but the next week it came back
and I do the same thing and I made a
play and then everybody got like quiet
like I cared not I just started people
for the faces of who they are and so for
me taking myself out of the game I look
at it what can I do outside the game who
can I help
what part of that can help someone else
be better in life I play it partner with
players coalition Boys and Girls Club
stars 24 you know feeding in hurricane
relief
I mean helping people out over there in
Texas the children and border cases I
mean I've been doing so much stuff I've
been doing a whole production and a
production company that I started a no
production it's not working with a guy
named Scotty and we're doing some
content that's development on my show
call um trolled controlled where they
aren't rofl which you learn more about
it
I'm also acting in it so it's so much
stuff that we were doing that I'm just
not even so much so concerned about you
know where we get in this game because I
know when the lights cut on in between
those lines I switch something else but
when we outside at week normal just like
the regular people walking up there it's
just they see us in a different light
because we're on TV man I appreciate you
I got love for you I'm gonna let you get
out of here man this was a very
interesting conversation for me man I've
always had respect now have so much more
because I've got a gotten a chance to
really delve into who you really are
Manning and what you're about and I love
that conversation with you and Odell on
the field yesterday that that that's
that's golden for me man
I appreciate your again Josh Norman on
the Rich Eisen show with prime
I'm himself I will appreciate you my
brother god bless you yes sir the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience